con el cierre de la votación para elegir
al sucesor de boris johnson cuyo nombre
se revelará el próximo lunes tanto
regional como list trans han aprovechado
twitter para enviar mensajes de
agradecimiento a todos sus seguidores
durante esta campaña los dos candidatos
se han autoproclamado como los herederos
fieles del legado de margaret thatcher
la conocida como dama de hierro que tuvo
que enfrentar en los años 80 una
fuertísima crisis económica en el país y
esa justamente será la prioridad del
nuevo premier británico enfrentar
adelantar e implementar medidas contra
la crisis en el costo de vida la
inflación que está disparada en un 10
por ciento y también el aumento en los
precios de la energía la prensa da como
un hecho que liz tras ser a la nueva
primera ministra siendo entonces y de
ser así la tercera mujer que llega a
este cargo aquí en el reino unido- en
toda su historia el martes la reina
isabel que es la jefa de estado en el
castillo de balmoral en escocia y no en
el palacio de buckingham aquí en londres
como lo hace tradicionalmente se reunirá
por separado con el primer ministro
saliente y con el primero la primera
ministra entrante a quien le pedirá que
forme un gobierno en su nombre y
entonces arrancará una nueva etapa un
nuevo gobierno del partido de
conservador